The answer is that the input should be a string
giving the contents of the rest of the web page.
That's how "get-next-target" works.
It finds the first target from the current page.
One way to see that, is to look at the code we're trying to replace.
This code defines lots of variables.
It gives them values.
The only one it uses on the right side, before giving it a value, is "page"
When it uses "start_link" on the right side here,
well the code defines "start_link" on the line above,
so, it didn't care about the value of "start_link" going into this code.
The only variable whose value we care about
going into this code
is the value of "page,"
and what "page" is, is a string
giving the contents of the rest of the web page.